Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome Alison Williams and Daniel Kaluuya for get out.
Hi,
thanks for joining us today.
Thanks for having us.
So let's start off with the beginning.
How did you both get involved in this project?
Um,
I got an email and a phone call from my agent and he was like,
I'm sending you a script that Jordan Peele I wanted me to send to you,
which triggered anxiety event number one that he knew who I was and wanted to
potentially to work with me.
It was mind blowing because I was a huge key and Peele fan because I'm a human
being who has eyeballs and likes things.
Um,
and so I,
I read the script and my agent also is like,
it's not a comedy.
So I thought,
oh,
that's so interesting.
So I read it and as I was reading it,
I was already getting excited about it.
And then I facetimed with Daniel Daniel with Jordan for like two hours and we
talked about Daniel and who might be part of it.
And it was like he was,
he was trying to convince me to do it,
but at the very beginning of our conversation,
I was like,
I'm so excited to do this.
And then he just kept trying to convince me and we had very similar experiences.
Yeah,
I'll read it.
And then
this is like 12 years a slave,
a horror movie.
And I was like,
I was like,
when boys would go crazy for this.
And then,
and then I emailed and they were like,
Jordan was to Skype with you.
And I said,
oh,
that's amazing.
I'm going to scrap the Jordan Peele does in the same and I don't even care.
I was,
I going to have this story forever.
And then,
uh,
and then,
then he was like,
he knows who you are.
I was like,
what even make sense.
And then I skyped with him and then he was watched black mirror to show.
I did back home a few years back.
And then like,
I was like,
Yo,
that's crazy.
That,
and then I realize it's Netflix is a thing out there.
And then,
and then,
um,
and yeah,
and he was really cool when I really,
I mean,
the script made me feel like I was like,
oh my God,
I can't believe you can say this.
You know what I mean?
I've got,
okay,
I definitely want to be a part of this.
And,
and Jordan just got it.
Yeah.
He's,
the script is amazing.
And he'd spent about five years working on it and just kind of mulling it over
and put it down and come back to it.
And,
um,
as a result of that,
there was just like,
it was so tight and it was so well crafted and I was just instantly excited
about it.
So Jordan not only wrote,
but he directed it.
Yes.
As you mentioned,
most of us probably know him from his comedy background,
the work he does now,
but what,
what was that sort of,
what's the most unexpected thing about having him at the helm of it?
And it was just kind of a daily thing where it's like,
oh yeah,
he's our director who takes you?
Yeah.
Like I got a text from Jordan Peele and I'm like,
oh,
uh,
those who I am.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah,
so he's just,
he's just so smart,
man.
And he's so on it and he's so collaborative and that's what it was the daily.
And then sometimes he'd be Tracy Morgan or whatever,
Kara Bama,
we needed energy.
He just direct,
he'd be really go into some other character,
but he's so talented as a director and the movie is great evidence of that.
But also like we had a firsthand daily experience of being directed by him,
which was amazing.
And he's collaborative,
but from when he really believes something needs to be a certain way,
which just as actors makes us trust him so much.
It's like having a parent that is strict when they need to be,
but understanding and collaborative and compassionate,
you know,
regardless.
So it's a,
he was phenomenal to work with and I would do whatever he asked of me.
Yes.
Are Our jobs in this movie are proof of that.
I'm just going to dive into this topic because you can't really talk about this
film without addressing race just because it's such an important part of this
entire film and it's,
it's at Google as a whole.
We've been having a lot of conversations about race and representation lately.
And I'm curious if like the process of making this film made you notice anything
about sort of behavior in the world in general that you might not have been
attuned to before.
I think probably this is mostly for me
because it goes both ways,
right?
Because like part of part of it is like,
Hey,
if you're of a different race and you're stepping into a scenario where you are
the outsider,
like it's,
it changes things and maybe before you didn't realize that you're that different
from other people and then your be your made hyper aware of it.
Yeah,
I think,
I think it's quite,
but I do think it's,
I think there's seminaries,
but I do think that being black in a,
in a,
in a different way,
environment is quite specific and it has his own specific specificity of,
uh,
of weirdness.
And a,
and just because I don't think racism is really weird.
I think racism is a really weird thing to,
for people to have an a and and,
and so,
yeah,
that's what the scripts at the party scene as a party scene.
And I was like,
and when everyone was kind of trying to make Chris feel welcome and comfortable
by keeping on asking the question about blackness.
And I was like,
I've been to that party,
I go to that point,
I'm going to bite you soon.
I don't know.
But I,
cause I,
it's like,
I've no doubt.
I know that and that and that's,
I don't know if any other Aviva it that's the same,
you know,
I don't think that's the same,
I don't think it manifest in the same way when people go,
I'm really cool with this.
Yo,
have you seen this basketball game and go,
Bro,
I'm English.
I don't care about bosket boo man.
I play watch football bro.
And I say that kind of,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
And I,
I was,
um,
I like to think of myself as someone who's pretty sensitive to that stuff.
And so in the script,
obviously I,
I caught all of that.
But I also think of myself as someone who's never done listening and learning
and trying to understand what it's like to go through life as someone else.
I can never fully know that,
but I can do my best every day to expand what I know of the human experience.
And so doing this movie was fascinating for me on multiple levels because I got
to,
well,
the whole audience gets to go through the movie from his eyes.
And so already you're subverting what is the typical horror trope of having the
final girl.
And so you're all,
you're typically going through a horror movie through a female,
a white woman's eyes,
and you're seeing it through the male gaze typically.
And so in this be subverted it doubly,
not only do we have a final boy,
but we have a black vinyl boy,
which is not a normal situation.
And so as a result,
the screenings of the movie reveal what Jordan earlier referred to as a Warshak
test,
which I love because the way you react to things in the movie and when,
um,
are really revolutionary about your own experience.
And if a lot of people in the audience who don't look like you are laughing at
something,
then it's worth investigating what that is and why you might not know about it.
And again,
apologies for how vague we're being,
but there are a lot of spoilers in this movie.
And so a lot of our answers sound like,
um,
bad press releases,
but we're just doing our best to not spoil stuff.
We're trying to preserve the experience for one thing because watching the film
and you know,
knowing what some of your referring to I had,
it's just a different experience.
So it is,
but it was actually interesting going back and seeing like the trailer again,
having seen the film and realizing this is totally a different experience then.
And I feel like we haven't actually seen a film like this ever.
Possibly because you have,
you know,
yeah,
that's what I was in a call.
We've shown the producer and then we just talk about life and then like,
and then he was like sort of by this film and took about why the budget is
really low and took my little stuff and he was like,
the thing is about his film,
it's never been done before.
This is the risk.
And I was like,
that's why I said yes.
That's exactly what,
and that's exciting.
Doing stuff like that is exciting because you're like,
we don't,
I don't know what's going to happen off the 24th.
I don't have no idea.
Like it's new territory,
new areas.
And that's why we're here for,
you know,
to do stuff that's different than,
yeah,
that's something that we immediately bonded over is that neither of us is
particularly interested in safety as far as our careers go,
which is very dumb,
like from an actual longevity standpoint.
But it's selfish because we want to keep challenging ourselves and keeping
ourselves guessing in terms of what's coming next.
Um,
and so I think we both get sent a lot of roles that we felt like we've played
itches,
we feel we've scratched.
And so then this comes along and both of us were just like,
oh my God,
this is not someone I'm ever going to be sent again.
Or if I ever seen this character before,
if I don't do this,
when will it ever happen?
So,
um,
but I,
I do think that this movie more than most is a really good communal viewing
experience for the reasons I gave before.
But also because it's told so carefully through the perspective of Chris,
um,
you,
the audience isn't ahead of him.
It's annoying and horror and the audience knows something that the protagonist
doesn't.
So you're literally like,
you feel
helpless in the way that he does if he's feeling helpless in that moment,
are empowered.
And so it's a really active participation movie.
We've,
there've been a bunch of screenings now at this point and all of them are very
vocal,
which is fantastic.
And then the second time you see the movie,
it's a completely different movie.
It's a totally different movie.
You have a different protagonists are not going to tell you who it is,
but you're suddenly watching the movie through somebody else's eyes.
And it's just a really cool narrative thing that Jordan did that we worked very
hard to like layer into all the performances.
Were you worried at all,
because you said you're not concerned with safety years but,
but you know,
to take this role you have to sort of embrace certain stereotypes.
I feel like the entire film depends on like society as a holes.
Assuming things about both of you.
Like so where,
where did you draw from in terms of like,
okay,
this is,
this is a moment where I really want to embrace like the kind of stereotype of
what,
what people are expecting from like a white woman.
I'm just going to say if I,
you know,
you can call me a white woman,
that's fine,
but I feel like,
you know,
a white woman has like certain connotations and where you at all like,
Hey,
I really just don't want to be associated with this.
Or having been a suburban white women my entire life,
I feel,
um,
I felt actually like I was excited to be able to play that archetype,
uh,
in such a kind of,
um,
outright way in this movie because it kind of De Thorns,
any association I have with that class,
so to speak,
going forward.
And it gives me a great excuse to not have to do it again.
So now I can kind of like I've done that.
I did the like Marnie version of it and I mean Peter Pan is not in this category
at all,
but you just white,
um,
English,
uh,
ageless flying.
Um,
boy,
but that's like a different thing entirely.
And then,
um,
but rose also feels like,
okay,
now I can kind of walk away from,
from this version of a person.
And it's also why Jordan wanted me to play it as he came to the widest girl to
play the widest girl.
And I was like,
yes,
I acknowledge that as my mantle and I will play at dutifully.
So
yeah,
I kinda,
I mean,
mean to Annetta conversation.
I really was wary.
I already wanted Chris to be not saying,
I mean excluding anyone else,
any of it,
but I really want Chris to be a black guy that black people root for,
because sometimes in this kind of arena he can,
like in those situations,
he could be seen as like not speaking up and not,
you know,
so it was very wary it,
especially at that party,
if someone said something,
I remember there was a scene.
Yeah,
you're like,
code switching too much.
It's not going to read.
Yeah.
It just go,
look,
he looks like a seller.
They will perceive it as a seller not being a sell out.
Is that how it's in the public consciousness and,
and,
and I was wary about that because you'd want them to go,
you want black beads,
which go,
I'd made that decision.
I understand that.
I understand it.
And I think the root of it is the fact that he loved his girlfriend.
I mean,
and he loves his girlfriend and he's like,
he's doing,
he's being vulnerable because of this bond.
And he has like real affection for it.
So he's willing to withstand certain comments.
And,
but he's aware that there's a comment he's not going,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's cool.
But he's like listening to them.
I know my politics,
I know what the situation is and I'm only choosing not to say certain things
because out of respect,
this is how um,
arena,
so that's for me,
I w I really want it to put,
cause obviously in the interracial relationships because of the conversation in
America,
some people think
that your not part of the black community because you're dating a white girl and
not and just kind of get into yeah,
exactly.
And that's such an interesting territory to,
so I had to be careful because I did want boys I grew up with like to go yo Nah.
Yeah,
I understand that.
I understand.
And then that's when the trailer came out,
how people that grew up,
we've got you,
I get that he's called pre go,
he's just a good guy and he's just,
and that's what the reaction I was reaching for.
I didn't want him to feel isolated in that sense.
And the nice thing for,
to that end is that Jordan kind of structured in this other arc,
uh,
for rose to be learning to see everything through his eyes too.
So their relationship comes out of a metropolitan setting where it's not very
unusual to see an interracial couple and then it goes into the suburbs.
It's not specified which city or which suburb,
which makes it scarier because you can't tell yourself that it wouldn't happen
where you live cause it could.
Um,
but the,
um,
when they leave this contacts that they're used to being in and returned to a
context,
it's really familiar to rose.
She starts to look at the world that she's always known in a completely new way,
and she's starting to observe people from without,
um,
with his insight.
And so suddenly the way that her dad is talking sounds weird to her.
He's saying,
my man,
and she's like,
I don't think I've ever heard him say my man.
And he's called,
he said that like 10 times as you got here.
Suddenly there's a bunch of things that she's noticing for the first time.
And so they're,
at least they're partnered in that sense.
She's not saying like,
no,
everyone's being normal.
What are you talking about?
She's like,
this is weird.
They're being weird.
I was so sure that they weren't going to be weird about it.
Um,
and you know,
it's subtle stuff but at least roses,
his partner and paying attention to it.
Dan,
you,
I'm curious because you aren't from here and as you mentioned,
like,
you know,
people assume like,
oh,
basketball and stuff like that,
but so much of this takes place,
like,
as you said,
a lot of the terror of it comes from like,
it's a suburb,
it's a very American seeming suburb.
Is that something that you were just inherently like,
no,
I totally get what's going on here?
Or did you have to do research on suburbs?
Basically?
It just seems like such a culture difference.
Um,
and I,
I just met me and that was like,
he was good at it.
I understand why you are,
this is great.
This is all the information need.
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
I had to latch on the,
onto the things that would truthful to me.
And I think there's an,
I do think in terms of England and America,
there are parallels and I feel I'm,
I'm working class and so growing up black working,
working class you you for and I'm black won't class doing a quiet middle class
job.
So I I I'm in some rooms that my life wouldn't have me in.
So you fulfill the same role in tones of it's like go into the house we went
into in the film is similar.
Go into uh,
I've been to that house with someone that owns a construction company.
I don't know why I was there.
I don't know how I got there.
I really want to get into this.
Yo Yo yo yo yo yo they had like they had a room.
Yeah,
they had a room.
I know this is maybe really normal if you're rich though.
But like they had a room.
Yeah.
Where you just wait to eat light.
There's a room Nan and it's like,
it's really English.
There's not going to eat.
I don't even have,
we have just like a sitting room.
Yeah.
Just like I see.
And when you eat vibes and everything,
they had a room where you wait before you go into the dining room.
A sitting room.
Is that what I it,
yeah,
I'm devastated.
My mother lives and Abby or the crown now obviously because of my job I opened.
That's wild to me.
Like there's just a room where you stand and wait there for like 10 minutes,
like every day.
And so he's like,
so that was that.
So that's what I'm trying to say.
You
Do,
you occupy the same positions within the social ladder and a social structure.
And so that's identified with that in the sense that Chris,
obviously he's a photographer so he's doing something quite autistic.
So that opens a woe to him.
And,
and I think,
I think,
you know,
I think a lot of people go,
I mean this is a debate,
it's happened in England where like they don't want to see any hood dramas like
drums out about working class.
But I think what's really honest,
it's something that was in Atlanta as well,
where he's like,
no,
it's certain people's lives or the fact that you get into really crazy poor
situations and you get into this massive mansion at the same time and you don't
belong in,
even though I love that episode of the Jay.
Yeah,
yeah.
You don't belong in the evo spaces anymore because you've tasted that and you
tasted that and it's just going,
I'm in the middle.
And that's why I really identified with Chris is that because of his job and
because of his passion,
he's meets someone,
let grows all open to date,
someone that rose and,
but he's not from that world and these aren't God.
I,
I think a lot of people around the world go free to experience and so,
and,
and you want to tell those stories that resonates internationally and you want
to find the truth,
the international truth as opposed to a specific cause that will help you to,
to layer.
This is the specificity of the story.
You tell it
you didn't know each other beforehand.
So there's a logic train to this that follow up.
I hope.
I hope you can follow along.
So one of the things from me,
I was like,
and this is just partially because we work at Google,
I was like man,
your character must have,
which is like zero digital footprint because you know,
I don't know if anyone's ever been tempted to like Google when they're starting
to date,
but um,
I feel like I'm
uh,
I think
thank you.
We're going to avoid this,
the up.
But it's an interesting,
that's an interesting,
that's a very,
we that it's an interesting question and a lot of time thinking about that.
I realize I was dating a lot.
Yeah.
And then what he's going to be like,
cause I'm not on social media and they'll be really frustrated because they
Google you like that's a thing now everyone googles everybody.
Well you're a famous actor.
That's not a problem.
Which mean they can Google you.
You have a yes,
but I want to know the personal stuff.
They want to know
two friends and want to know what all that stuff like they want to know.
No.
So my question is,
where are you tempted?
Did you Google each other before going into,
I'm sorry.
It was not,
yeah,
no,
we've run into this problem a lot.
Doing press for the movie.
There's like a point where the we can't,
no,
I,
I don't know about it,
but it made me,
honestly,
the point in the film made me think about like,
hey,
I was already a fan of his,
because I love skins,
which was originally at a show in the UK and he was in skins and I also loved
his episode of Black Mirror.
And I was a big [inaudible] fan.
It was like a little creepy,
honestly,
the amount that I really respected his work.
And Jordan,
when he told me that it was going to be Daniel,
he was like,
it's this actor Daniel Kaluuya.
And he started to describe him and I was like,
no,
no.
I know exactly what you guys,
because after that episode of Black Mirror,
I was like,
who is this person?
Because it was so striking and,
and,
and beautifully done.
And so I didn't need to do a lot of googling.
I think I knew who is Ugandan cause I was curious or I am an English by way of
Uganda in a big way.
Um,
yeah.
I mean yeah.
It's an inappropriate for me to didn't respond kind.
No,
no,
no.
It's best for you gone.
Right.
I'm just doing the inappropriate points.
No,
cause this is awkward enough.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
but that's how much I knew about you.
Uh,
I watched the first season that goes and I thought she was great.
She was so great.
Yeah.
She's not good enough to keep up.
Keep watching though.
No,
you wouldn't leave me.
That's how great cause I can invest in.
I was like,
no,
the money.
Why is she doing that?
Remember got your conversation about,
I was like,
no,
but she did this thing.
Yeah.
And this is the day to day and it's because I've been through those situations.
She did his thing.
It's his thing and then when my friend goes,
but that,
that's what makes it really great.
That's what makes her really great because you felt it and I was like,
yeah,
I'll call it what Jack.
Oh,
what's it for?
A bit.
And then,
and then I found that she was in it and I was out definitely not watching it
because I found out she was in get up because it would make me to cell phone.
I just wanted to meet Alison do I mean and and just,
you know,
can you can kind of take it like the other day I met,
I met chance the rapper was an idiot man.
I just some silly stuff and I was,
I showed him a video of my friend dies and these concert lays,
it makes it weird.
Like do you mean now that I get weird in those situations?
So I try and keep ignorant.
I go,
ah,
Alison,
cool,
love your work.
And then I haven't and I say I keep it moving.
And then we had a long car ride to go.
We went to like a cast or treat too on the water.
And so I was like,
I will drive Daniel.
And he was probably like,
Oh God,
and you're pretty private dude.
But I was,
I mean pretty much,
yeah.
You just went on like a diatribe against social media.
Yeah.
No,
it's not even that.
I just don't,
I just don't post publicly.
Yeah,
that was your private,
literally that's the devil
definition
because this is being normal.
And then if you'll be in public,
that's an effort.
That's it.
I got it.
Got It all out of him and it's now I'm also going to keep it private until you
decided to just live out loud,
man.
Live your chairs.
You hit my truth and just be out there.
No,
I just,
I just keep it moving here.
We have time for one or two audience questions if anyone wants to line up.
Um,
I,
I would love to know just because independent of any of the scarier horror stuff
that happens in this film meeting someone's family is very awkward when you're
in a relationship.
Have you either of you ever had a like a horror story about meeting eat friends,
whatever,
somebody else's like input the important people in their lives?
Yeah.
It's weird cause it's exact same thing happened to you,
right?
No,
no,
I'm kidding.
No,
no,
no.
I remembered a novel one.
You didn't,
we've been asked this question a lot and it's always disappointing cause neither
of us has very awkward but yeah,
but in number one,
so I had my first girlfriend.
What's the play watching this play now and this is Danny and what cultured 17 no
big deal,
you know is great.
They play at 17 yeah
18 and then a and then I came out and then like,
and then she was like,
she got a text goes no,
she got to take it from a mum.
And it was like,
Oh my God,
my dad's here have died.
Found out that never knew that we would like having a situation.
So at that found that way was go out,
have a mum and then drove to the feet and outside right to pick her up.
And I was like,
what?
What was happening?
Cause Oh my God,
I'm going.
She started crying and stuff.
She goes upstairs and he was just waiting outside looking for like waiting
outside of it.
Let's say she was on,
what did she lie about where she was
sheets.
She told her mom because her mom was cool with it,
but the dad wasn't cool with it.
And then so then I came out and I know she's mixed race
black coffee.
No,
I know what that means is she just didn't want,
I've been only in America,
people don't know what that means.
Right.
He's some fucking credit,
one drop rule.
I don't understand this waiver,
but um,
but yeah,
so she was like,
uh,
he was outside
and I was like,
oh,
cool.
And then she had to like,
go ahead.
She goes,
okay,
I'm going to hustle without going into it.
And he just went crazy.
It was like getting a car getting in and I was like,
ah.
Yeah.
That's a good story.
Yeah,
no,
I completely forgot about it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I've got nothing really.
It's all been pretty
Smith.
Hi.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
[inaudible] your sweatshirt.
Thank you.
Lemonade all day.
Yep.
So my question is actually for Alison.
Um,
so when girls was coming out,
there was a lot of controversy and conversation of course,
about race and the show.
And so it's very interesting to see you now in a film that is so kind of race
forward and really taking it on.
I don't think I've heard kind of what your thoughts were during that
controversy.
Like what were you thinking,
how would you have responded to some of that critique and what do you think that
this movie will have you kind of bringing to future projects in terms of like a
heightened door,
maybe a different sort of a,
yeah,
racial consciousness.
Thank you for that question.
Um,
I would say that I'm not really interested in,
and this is something that Lena and Jenny also share,
like going forward,
I'm not interested in doing something that is that one dimensional racially,
um,
just as like a blanket rule,
but beyond being interested,
it just doesn't feel reflective of my life and the demographics of the people
that I spend time with.
Um,
the other thing is that I,
um,
this is,
an issue that I think about a lot and when the show came out and was getting
that criticism,
it was something that I had noticed.
But I also knew that due to how intimate it was for Lena to,
since she basically wrote it all for her to have,
um,
tried to write someone else's experience,
she may have failed miserably in that,
could have been just as bad.
So,
um,
I totally thought the criticism was legitimate.
Um,
but I also was like a baby 22 year old who is just trying to figure out what was
happening to me and I wasn't going to like full throated Lee be like,
here's the problem I have with this situation.
But I think she was right.
She wrote,
you know,
she wrote two characters from each part of her,
cultural heritage and that felt like something she had the authority to write.
And,
um,
everything that I'm currently working on and everything that I intend to do
going forward is,
has to do with a lot of this,
I mean,
with disability,
with race,
with,
uh,
feminism,
all of that.
That's my,
I actually like live in that,
in those spaces in my free time and all the work that I do extracurricularly has
to do with all of these issues.
I just,
I prefer to let the work,
I do speak for itself rather than talk,
talk,
talking about it.
I,
I like listening more and learning because,
um,
that's my job.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Hi,
I'm Angela Lynn and I'm a really big fan of girls and when I first thank you,
okay,
you were going to be and get out.
I was like,
what is Marnie going to do?
Feeling like Alison Williams can really fucking act.
Thank you.
Oh,
thank you.
One question that I have is thinking about how you felt as Alison Williams and
as Daniel Kaluuya Kaluuya yeah.
About the film.
So when I left,
it was a very visceral experience for me and I actually went home and cried for
like a number of reasons.
Um,
but I'm wondering as not as actors,
but like as people,
how did you feel about that film?
And that sounds really flowery,
but I'm sure.
No,
no,
totally snow flurry tool.
I fell,
I,
it wasn't fun for me.
No,
it was kind of how racism feels like.
Yep.
For me.
[inaudible] I've been there,
I've been up in that place where I'm,
um,
I've got so much rage,
I've got so rage and it mirrored how my insides are sometimes the last 20
minutes I call it,
I know it.
And I didn't know that in the script.
I didn't,
I knew it,
but I didn't,
I didn't have the words for it as yet.
But when I watched it and I saw it and I sort of,
and it's like,
yeah,
get this blood because of racist,
this blood and racism,
man,
people die every day for it die every day,
but a hundred the law,
you know and it,
and every time you see it on the screen get you because that person looks at
you,
the person that's like your Auntie,
that person that's like a cousin
go easy.
She just,
no,
I'm not.
I'm,
Say it to him saying that,
hey racist to me.
She's cool.
No,
no,
I just,
I read,
she said she went,
she was very by it.
I'm just saying it's like that's your aunt.
That's your though.
That's not,
it's really now I know when people dial out,
they ain't no,
ain't no pull back from that mum that's says no son,
you know,
there ain't nothing.
And so it felt like,
it felt,
it was a visceral,
it was Kinda,
it stayed in me when watching it and I was at mine like this is,
this is,
and that paranoia and it just the arc of the paranoia and not knowing who to
trust and not,
I'm feeling and being in the situation when no one sees you,
you know,
can you,
and for whatever reason,
you know,
when someone goes,
you don't see me,
you can't get it,
can't communicate.
We speak completely different languages.
Yeah.
We're talking English Josanna and it's like I felt that I'm watching it and it
was,
it was,
it was tough,
but it was entertained at the same time.
So it was quite weird and I was just like,
oh man.
But then I felt cool cause I was like,
this is very important,
you know,
cause it's about a feeling it as opposed to box office and x,
y,
zed or x,
zed in it.
So I was really proud of Jordan the,
he put his reputation on the line to make the story happen.
Yeah.
I personally,
I also felt um,
upset after the first time I saw it.
I was excited because it,
it,
I knew it would be noisy and I knew it would be disruptive and that was what we
did it for.
After I watched it,
I was like,
this is as good as it needed to be.
I'm so thrilled.
I think it will be seen by the people who need to see it and hopefully they'll
see it in theaters with people who don't share their background and they'll
learn a little bit about the way they look at the world.
Um,
my experience of playing rose and going through all that she goes through,
um,
is,
was in the moment.
Of course I had to like be her.
So that was one experience.
But then watching it back,
it's,
I feel shame on behalf of a lot of people that I don't feel that I am related to
or that it's my actual legacy.
But just as a general idea,
I feel a lot of shame about it.
And so in that sense,
I feel pride for having breathe life into her so that people can look at her and
her whole family critically.
And even if rose feels like she's a victim of something bigger than she is,
um,
or however you want to look at her eye,
that critical.
I was something that I worked very hard to,
to breathe life into in a way that people could,
could a lot of ways about being very vague again.
Um,
but I,
um,
I basically worked hard to make people feel a lot of things about my character
that we're going to be maybe uncomfortable for them.
Um,
and I recognize that that was my job in this movie.
And um,
my job was to be a support system for Daniel as Chris and,
um,
to help people live through his eyes instead of mine,
which is what they're used to doing.
Um,
and I was very happy to do that,
to do my part.
Great job.
Thanks.
I think that's a great note to wrap up on.
I think this movie brings a lot of food for thought,
and thank you so much for joining us today.
Thanks for having us.
Thank you for your questions.